would limiting people's use of digital
life be good only a certain amount of
likes shares characters etc per day from
dusty green
this is an excellent excellent
suggestion dusty
yes giving people a certain amount of
karma to give out to other users
would in fact
throttle the amount of virality in these
networks however that would work against
their
obvious financial incentives
and a lot of crypto people have pointed
out maybe you should pay
a certain amount so if you got if you
paid ten dollars a month for facebook or
for reddit you would get a certain
number of upvotes and you see this on
youtube now there's something called
super chat so every time knicks fan tv
comes on they had the opening game of
the knicks we were up by almost 30
points at some points in time i'm not
going to over hype it it's just a
preseason game but the knicks are
winning 71 games this season uh that's
my prediction no it's not 46 wins is my
prediction i think we'll be above 500.
uh we're gonna be a great team look
great last night but you can give a
super chat and then you get pinned to
the top right and so there is a way to
tie economic
incentive to your karma or participation
you can do and so i think that that's a
clever idea and it could actually make
more money for them so if you said hey
let's uh you know incorporate crypto
into this i think that's why zuckerberg
was looking into doing crypto a big
ramification of what we're seeing with
facebook is the fact that their crypto
project has been essentially
neutered throttled
i don't want to say doa because who
knows where its status it's in but they
were supposed to have this crypto you
know libra thing was going to change the
world and where is it i think that they
do not
they have so much influence in the world
facebook that they're like replacing the
monetary supply
when we're screwing up elections and
people perceive us to be screwing up
kids
they don't want us touching the money
next like you screwed up democracy our
children and now you're going to screw
and screw up thanksgiving and now you're
going to screw up the monetary supply no
thank you facebook so that's a real
world ramification